cutoff pointing
if it depends on the Russian Federation
there will be no war, we don’t want a warrior, but
we also won’t allow to attack our interests rudely to ignore our interests,
and
they use Zelinsky in the regime, they
use it before the Americans in order
to escalate tension attract
their
Cossacks in Europe who  they
play along in every possible way in Russophobic undertakings, and
this main goal of Washington in this
case is not at all the fate of Ukraine, it is important for them to
escalate tension around the
Russian Federation about the evacuation,
I do not exclude that whoever evacuates the
Americans and other Anglo-Saxons of the Canadian
to the British means they know
something that the rest of me do not know  I would think now,
maybe we, too, in anticipation of
some kind of provocation from the outside,
take precautionary measures
against our diplomats, and you
only received answers the day before yesterday that, well, in
such a Western style
cast a shadow over the wattle fence in many ways, but there
are rational grains, as I already
said on  a secondary issue  I am not
sending official requests to all my
colleagues with a
direct appeal to officially explain
how they are going to fulfill, in the current
historical conditions, the obligations under
which their countries have signed at the highest
level, and I have already said this in a presentation
if our attempts to agree on
mutually acceptable principles for ensuring
security in Europe do not
work then  we will take
retaliatory measures by
answering a direct question what these measures
can be, he said they can be
very different, I will make decisions
based on the proposals that
our military will present to me, of course,
other departments will also participate
in the preparation of these proposals, at
least now it is underway  interdepartmental
study of the responses received from the United States and
NATO, and their content is
already known to almost everyone against the background of the paper
that the American response was sent to us from NATO,
but is almost
an example of diplomatic
decency  he breathes so much the
exclusivity of the North Atlantic
Alliance, his special missions, a special
purpose, that I was just a
little ashamed of those who wrote these texts,
we'll see, but in the next couple of
weeks there should be another meeting, but
now it's on the part of the Americans, well,
you know, they say we have such a bargain for the
ambassador  it is imperative that
you have twelve people just
serving him if this rudeness
continues but we still have reserves
in order to really equalize
our diplomatic presence
[applause]